a major major corporate power story a
major lobbying story a major crony
capitalism story that I must talk about
today late last week the Senate voted to
get rid of privacy rules requiring
internet service providers to ask you
for permission before they can sell or
share your web browsing history with
advertisers and other companies this was
a rule established during the Obama
presidency in October of last year at
the time the FCC was controlled by
Democrats it has been undone and your
internet service provider is now one
step closer to being able to do whatever
the hell they want with your private
information and this information would
be hugely valuable to advertisers it
would let them see more about your
social life your buying habits probably
figure out all sorts of stuff including
your home address places you've been
endless data now this is actually the
surprising part because I've said it
before there are huge differences
between Republicans and Democrats on
many issues but on many issues involving
corporations and corporate power the
parties are almost identical the Senate
vote was almost completely down party
lines all Democrats voted against it and
all Republicans voted for it other than
the two Republicans who didn't vote at
all this was part of all of the
Congressional review Act that Congress
has been enacting lately where they've
been able to do away with many Obama era
policies they've also prevented privacy
rules from being reinstated in the
future now Republicans are framing this
as hey we're trying to curb overbearing
regulations on communications companies
was it really overbearing to allow
consumers to have some reasonable
privacy when they were using the
Internet Senator Ed Markey from here in
Massachusetts said about this quote
President Trump may be outraged by fake
violations of his own privacy but every
American should be alarmed by the very
real violation of privacy that will
result from the Republican rollback of
broadband privacy protections now this
does still need to pass the house until
it's officially
made law and then of course Donald Trump
would also have to sign it but the point
is it's not too late to call your
elected officials on this this is an
obvious disgusting intrusion into our
privacy and it's a classic example Pat
of conservatives are blindly going with
their the the anti the the abandonment
of any regulation and they they push it
under the idea of over small government
we're talking about just basic people's
privacy here and this is a handout for
ISPs to make even more money they're
already gouging you on price and
providing subpar service now on top of
it they're gonna be able to make more
money by selling your your preference to
advertisers and I'm sure if you polled
the American public on that there would
be in wide support of keeping the Obama
era regulation absolutely absolutely
right
as long as some of them you wouldn't
want to tell them that it was an Obama
regulation you would just say are you in
favor of this rule and overwhelmingly
people would say absolutely at my
browsing history shouldn't be sold but
who would be in favor of this the ISPs
the Internet service providers companies
like Verizon AT&T Comcast and those are
the people that not only fund the
campaigns for these congressmen and
Senators but also fund media outlets
like MSNBC and Fox News and the rest of
the cable outlets it's the whole
corporate media industrial complex and
everything that I've been telling you
about for years and how could a single
Republican not vote against this you
have to wonder what kind of money
changed hands here what kind of promises
were made behind the scenes for this to
pass there are people online saying if
the resolution passes we should create a
GoFundMe page so that we could buy the
internet browsing histories of the
senators who voted for this I don't know
that it'll exactly work like that but
the good news is there are many groups
working on these issues the ACLU the
Electronic Frontier Foundation our
friends over at Free Press who are
actually fighting to keep these rules in
place so there are good groups doing
work on exactly this issue I think it
really is one of those issues where if
you call your career representative
they'll actually respond because they
may think they can get away with it if
it doesn't get media attention but if
you show that actually people are paying
attention to this they may change their
mind this is like the whole SOPA PIPA
situation from a couple
years back absolutely call your elected
officials on this one and send me your
thoughts about this on Twitter I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show